here are some questions that i got from
malibu magazine and so i thought i would
answer them so question number one your
videos began as a means of tutoring your
cousins and now exist as a resource to
educate the world which must be hugely
inspiring and yes it is and a bit
surreal your model is hyper scalable
because any one lecture can be viewed an
infinite number of times anywhere but
it's also very dependent on your
personal input do you ever feel
overwhelmed by the idea of having to
record one more or based on expectations
hundreds of more videos or every or ever
question the notion that you should be
the khan academy's only lecturer so in
the first part do you ever feel
overwhelmed um
not not in the way uh that i guess it
sounds like this is phrasing i'm
actually this is what is really exciting
about me and almost from my own selfish
point of view uh this is one of the
reasons why i love doing this is that i
get to spend the rest of my life um
doing what i really enjoy which is which
is which is teaching and and many times
learning and teaching so you know or or
teaching myself a new way of looking at
something or getting to make connections
between things that i've never been able
to uh have the luxury to explore before
so i view it as a luxury more than uh
something that would overwhelm me so so
i really i really love this aspect of of
getting to do more and more videos and i
and i hope that i i never um that you
know as long as i live i'm able to
continue to make making videos and and
at least hundreds more per year um that
which which you know i even though there
is a lot of responsibility of of the
organization and being one of the the
people who helped manage what is now
this organization that's beyond me the
khan academy i always want to be
spending a significant amount of my time
making videos because that's really what
i what i love um and then the second
part of it you ever question the notion
that you should be the academy's only
lecturer and that's that's a a big yes
and
but the answer to that has never been
completely obvious because we i i think
one of the reasons why we've gotten a
lot of traction is the consistency and
the trust and because when you learn
from someone it actually takes a lot of
trust to invest your own mental cycles
in them and and i think um
people have you know kind of have
learned to trust the khan academy and so
we never thought that it should be this
kind of
you know thing that everyone can can
throw stuff videos on in fact there are
already things that it's called youtube
or other things like it um and we think
you know it's jarring when you have
different quality and you have different
teachers even if they are good and so
that's what we struggled with and we
also think that there's kind of a an
understanding an agreement with the
student that
content on the khan academy will focus
on conceptual development over
mechanical understanding it'll be
conversational it won't talk down to the
student it will talk to everyone as if
they are smart but not talk but not talk
in a way that assumes that someone knows
all the terminology or or kind of not
talk past people
and so it's been very important that
that we bring and and nothing sounds
scripted everything sounds authentic
everything is directly coming from a
person that's kind of a person-to-person
communication not a
corporation-to-person communication and
so these are surprisingly hard things to
find and we've been searching and what
you'll see in the next few months is we
actually are bringing on some other
lecturers partic in particular the
humanities uh who will be lecturers in
the humanities and uh
i love them the the videos that i've
watched of theirs made me wish that i
had them as teachers when i was growing
up and
i hope other people have that same
reaction
and the other thing that
people have begun to notice is the last
few weeks we've been experimenting with
bringing contributors in who i kind of
interview and we're experimenting with
that form factor to see if it's
something that that makes sense or maybe
something that just complements the
broader library i'll always be doing the
independent traditional you know sal
teaching type of thing but i i've really
been enjoying getting these experts in
and being able to kind of play the
student role
so
the simple answer is yes we have
questioned it and over the next few
months you're going to see actually the
the faculty of the khan academy expand
in a pretty substantial way
question number two one of the most
difficult things for people to wrap
their heads around is the idea that
you're not interested in monetizing the
academy cold hard cash pails next to the
intrinsic value of the tools you've
created and their attendant legacy but
if the academy will never be a source of
wealth do you think you'll eventually
turn your attention to another
for-profit driven venture
so the simple answer is ab no no i um
you know
this i've gone through the um
the mental uh
simulation multiple times is if if if
someone were to give me a billion
dollars this exact this is exactly what
i would want to do and so i get a chance
to do it now so regardless of whatever
happens uh
if for whatever reason you see sal
saying hey i'm done with the khan
academy i now want to go start managing
money again or if i want to go start
doing x or y uh people should uh uh you
know wonder whether i've been abducted
and replaced by someone else because i
have i i consider myself the luckiest
person on the planet that i get to do
what i'm doing now and hopefully for the
rest of my life uh and hopefully it's
it's a decent respectably long life but
you know you never know um
yes and so uh and you know you've
articulated in the question exactly i
mean i think
you know i'm not
i'm not someone who doesn't mind a
little bit of cold hard cash but at the
same time uh the
the the satisfaction of people really
enjoying this stuff we're genuine about
it we really love it i think it's not
just me it's most of our team if you
look at the people on the khan academy
team
some of them are actually
very well known in their in their
respective domains and even those that
aren't well known they really are all
rock stars we are really bringing on
this is really the most um amazing team
that i've ever worked with and i've
worked with a lot of very very smart
people in the past and they've all
turned away uh
higher paying jobs
jobs at you know pre-ipo companies where
they could make millions of dollars to
work on this project and so it's not
just me i am actually surrounded by
people who are similarly inspired by
this mission and and uh i hope that they
continue to want to do this for for a
long time um
question number three question number
three when you say that you'd like to
make the academy self-sustaining in five
years what do you mean i if you don't
charge for the videos what will be the
source of funding so we are this is this
is this not charging for the videos this
is kind of core to our religion of the
khan academy not the khan academy's
religion the court of what we hold dear
um
and and that's true also for our our
software um and as far as what the
source of funding will be you know it's
an open question i mean there's there's
ideas on the table
uh
one could be
um
you know
maybe and i don't know what all of the
ideas are me you know we are building a
hopefully a trusted brand here and maybe
you know the way sesame street does it
you know people um they license elmo out
so i don't know maybe maybe maybe i i
have to say that half jokingly but
that's how that's one way that the the
that sesame street has has really um
kind of supported themselves and and we
think we're kind of like sesame street
but for for older kids uh and adults um
in terms of we're making learning
approachable for them so maybe that type
of model might work um
we do hope that foundations continue to
support us forever to some degree i mean
we don't want to be 100 relying on that
but we do think relative to
the the impact it's having it's it's you
know
our budget is still smaller than most
individual schools even elementary
schools and we're able to reach millions
of students now and the same content
that's already produced can reach tens
of millions for for a long long time
we also hope that our user base supports
us we definitely don't mind if people
say wow that really helped me let me go
to paypal or let's let let's send khan
academy twenty dollars or let me give
them five dollars from my paycheck every
month if they can afford it um and so we
hope that that people are already doing
that and as our user base grows we think
that could also help us so the simple
answer is we we always want to have no
barrier to accessing the knowledge but
we do think that there will be ways over
the next five to ten years so that we
can at least support our base salaries
and our operating expenses so that this
resort that this resource never goes
away but we don't want to be complacent
about that so i do encourage people
people to to donate
question number four
what influence
have the gates foundation and other
donors had on the scope or evolution of
the academy
example is it now collect is it now
collaborative effort and if so what are
their objectives and how might they
differ from yours so at a first level uh
our our supporters gates foundation is a
large supporter
google is another major supporter we've
had several major individual uh
supporters uh they've they've treated us
in a great way you know there are
obviously people who who whose opinion
we really
want and and want to take into account
but they have said look what's what's
made khan academy work is it's kind of
grassroots y'all have tried stuff and
y'all saw what works and and based on
what works you keep doing more of it and
you keep iterating on the process and so
they've given us a lot of freedom to
explore the space and make decisions on
our own and and pursue the things that
we've found or
are compelling for our students but with
that said uh they are you know they have
a bunch of good ideas and so we are
taking those great ideas into
consideration and i think the one thing
that the the especially the gates
foundation has brought to the table is
that they've really plugged us into
a lot of the other stuff that's going on
in education education research and um
kind of helping to make those
connections and i think it's helping us
to uh
you know from khan academy from being
just like this kind of quirky thing that
one guy did and we want to keep it a
quirky thing but it also helps us
interface with with the more you know
the more
authoritative side of the education
world
question number five
your videos are now being leveraged to
drive more intense classroom learning by
flipping the classroom as i've said and
as i've said in many videos we view this
flip as halfway the idealist kids using
the software in the videos to work at
their own pace anytime and then they use
class time for the real interventions
and interactions with their peers and
you have had some very clear opinions
about how to improve the educational
experience i just gave one of them do
you have any aspirations around a larger
role in educational reform so i've
learned so reform seems like a good word
but i've learned that it can be a loaded
word and so if this question is do i
have do i want a role as like a
a state superintendent of education or a
no no the answer is a very clear no i
don't want to get involved at all in the
political debate i think um
i i think we are valuable or we can be
valuable or let me put it this way we
strive to be valuable to everyone and so
we don't want every anyone to have a
predisposition against us just because
sal says he feels
x y and z about some some you know hot
button issue there so if that's the
question we say no
if it's if it's do we want to be a
catalyst and maybe the reform
conversation being a clear thinking
conversation maybe when you know now
maybe we can provide common ground maybe
everyone in the debate agrees that class
time is better spent when it's
interactive everyone agrees that ideally
students should be
allowed to work at their own pace
everyone agrees that teachers are adding
are adding more value are going up the
value chain when they are mentors when
they are diagnosing students when they
are providing things that let that
videos and and and on on-demand
exercises can't when everyone agrees
that it's really valuable for teachers
to get real-time data so that they can
make those interventions in a valuable
way so we hope that we we're a catalyst
or we have aspirations about serving
those functions about
maybe clarifying or finding common
ground but i have no aspirations at all
about becoming some type of uh
you know a pundit in the
on the kind of political debates around
this
question number six
what's the most important thing you've
learned through the process of
establishing and growing the academy and
have there been any unintended
consequences
i i think um
the most important thing is i've learned
the power it's something that i always
suspected kind of within you know
engineering background but the power of
you you need to be kind of close to the
the person who the consumer or the end
user and then to to really understand
the problems and then you should try to
put something out that's even very
simple and basic and see if it works and
not make any assumptions that more
technology is good or fancier is better
but just try to solve the the need at
hand but try to solve it quickly don't
try to plan and talk about it for years
and and get funding and do all the stuff
before
you've tried stuff out so the big
takeaway i've had you know it's kind of
my way i would have operated beforehand
but it's really made me feel even
strongly about this is
build uh test and iterate things and and
and don't and don't get into you know
weeks-long debates that you know focus
on the meanings of words and whether one
research study is saying one thing or
the other research study is saying the
other
just build stuff put it out there and
and see if it works
and you know the unintended
is is that this idea of a lot of what
khan academy is doing is i think obvious
and and people have been talking about
this for a long long time
but i think that attitude of just look
let's not talk about it let's let's do
something about it um it has allowed us
to get get traction um in a space where
where there really hasn't been a lot of
traction from from things like what
we're doing
question number seven
you are super numerate and offer lots of
performance data to leverage teachers
efforts our teachers many of whom may
not be as naturally data centric
embracing these tools or are you finding
resistance what other criticisms are you
hearing from professional educators or
administrators so the first part of it
are we finding resistance um no not at
all you know the teachers who we've been
working closely with who've actually
been helping to define some of these
tools
they love it and if anything their their
main feedback is you know some of the
fifth grade teachers they teach all the
subjects so now they feel they feel
unarmed with data when they're teaching
other subjects so they want us to go
into those other subjects as quickly as
possible so they can start to have that
data so that the teachers i i we found
really do love the data and in terms of
what other criticisms are you hearing
from professional educators you know i
think some criticism is what is new here
uh you know hey isn't this just isn't
this just lecture and look even those
lectures aren't using anything fancy
they're just literally a guy chatting
about something with with uh you know
and kind of writing on a board and uh
they're right there isn't anything new
here and uh and i think what they're
missing the point is
it's not always about the idea it's a
lot is about the craftsmanship or or
what happens on the ground and i think a
lot you know especially the publishing
companies i think they missed the point
that
that human to human interaction that
it's important with real humans but it's
also important when it's human
interacting with a product they don't
want to feel like something is
overproduced they want to feel like
they're talking to someone who cares and
um and and it's also more important to
focus on
deep understanding and conceptual
understanding and why a subject is
beautiful it's more important to focus
on that than on fancy graphics and on
fancy you know whatever you know i try
to improve my penmanship and i try to
improve you know i try to draw nice
diagrams to to so people understand
things but we never are going to be that
place that makes that says we have the
fanciest graphic i mean maybe maybe if a
really fancy graphic is compelling we'd
want to integrate it but we won't we
don't want to do it just for the sake of
it just to improve impress other people
in the computer graphic space that we
have the best one um so that's one kind
of knee-jerk reaction of like wait this
is pretty basic what you know what why
is why is this interesting and you know
the answer is it is pretty basic but
maybe to some degree that is why it's
interesting that is why it's it's it's
it's it's why people are finding it
compelling the other interesting you
know i think the other reaction we get
is when we
when they learn when some people learn
about look you know kids learning at
their own pace using software uh people
using videos to learn
they
they believe that this is a somehow
trying to replace the classroom or
trying to replace the the uh the
interaction with the teacher and uh for
us we just think that's a misconception
we think we're the exact 180 degrees
opposite we are catalyst for enhancing
the interaction with the teacher the
teacher will now will no longer be
lecturing at the students they will now
be discussing with students they will
now be having those small group
discussions that that everyone i think
recognizes is the best way to learn
they'll now be leading projects that i
think everyone agrees is a really great
way to learn especially if it's
augmented with kids getting a lot of
practice and being able to get a lot of
their core skills uh to some degree um
at their own pace uh so so
you know i think i think those are the
the really uh two uh areas and you know
there's some resistance about about the
idea of of more voices um on the khan
academy and that's you know i already
talked about it earlier we are bringing
more voices to the table and we do want
to make tools so that the teachers
themselves can also uh contribute to the
platform and and all of that's coming
and we're gonna have the crowd hopefully
if we can think of a good way curate uh
what makes sense to add in but we want
to do all of that without losing a lot
of the consistency and even the
quirkiness that we think makes khan
academy work right now
number eight the content is heavily
weighted towards math and science what's
your plan for building more humanities
content and how do you choose what to
add to the site and when for example
what drove the decision to add a
playlist about the paulson financial
bailout versus another series of history
lessons
so our plan on the humanities the answer
is yes we actually are
actually i think they accept it today
and we're going to make the announcement
once we integrate some of their
work more deeply with the site but we've
brought on two professors in the
humanities and and i love what they've
already done so i hope everyone can
start getting excited about it because i
think they'll be pretty happy with what
they've done and i think they've tackled
the humanities in a very interesting way
in fact this new technique of me doing
conversations with people this was
inspired by them because the humanities
and many of the humanities are very
subjective and they've
got this really neat way of having a
conversation about subjective things
that bring more than one a way to think
about something to light and i think it
also encourages students to think of
what their own opinions about something
are not just to take the professor's
opinion as as you know the as gospel
and then for example what drove the
decision to add a playlist about the
pulse and financial bailout versus
another series of history lessons
that one in particular was a mist of the
financial crisis and i just saw stuff on
tv that i thought was wrong
i was still working at a hedge fund then
and i was spending most of my time
reading you know the federal reserve act
and i was reading all of the details of
a lot of these bailouts and it just felt
like there was a huge gap between what
what the public understanding was and
what the real reality was and i also
thought that it was a very unbalanced
conversation in the public uh that you
know
essentially this thing was being
steamrolled forward uh the the the take
from the uh the the interested parties
was trust us on this bail us out if you
if you even think about it for another
day we have a gun to the economy or a
bomb is about to blow up the economy and
we're all going to you know everything's
going to go to hell in a handbasket if
we don't if we don't address those
issues and so um you know i thought
another more hopefully rational voice
was needed because there were some very
irrational things happening so it was
really just and people were asking me a
lot of questions at parties and things
and so i was like hey let me scale up my
answer
but the general idea is there's a
constant tension between what is a
useful um
you know hey look we still haven't done
those type of algebra videos let's do
those um and you know there's just stuff
that's current events that needs
answering and then there's just some
quirky things that i just happen to run
into that i find interesting and i'm
just dying to make a video and i'll do
those so it's a constant balance between
all of those things
question number nine
your faq answer on your website about
your religion is very eloquent but why
did you feel compelled to put it on the
side at all did people in fact
frequently ask about your religious
beliefs um
yes
there were there is a
that many people did ask about my
religious beliefs and they wanted
confirmation one way or the other about
my religion and so i thought that the
that fact answer was actually the best
way to address that question because
that is actually how i feel about my
religion
question number 10
question number 10 the american
educational system is broken in many
ways but we also have a problem of
misallocation of resources and that
highly educated minds gravitate towards
hedge funds investment banks and other
lucrative professions and away from
teaching in other professions that are
more productive for society as a whole
given your highly relevant personal
career shift do you have any ideas about
how to change that mis allocation
you know i think people go into a career
for multiple reasons i think one is you
know intellectual stimulation and
teaching is
as or more intellectually stimulating
than many of those other higher paid
careers they go into something for
compensation and that's something where
at least definitely at the k-12 level
there isn't that compensation
and they also go into it for respect
and the one example i give here is is
professors um you know there isn't any
crisis about of of great minds going
into academia uh even though even though
academia really has uh you know the
compensation
academia even though it's just as
competitive to become a tenured
professor at a great university actually
more competitive to become a tenured
professor at a university than make
partner at a prestigious bank or hedge
fund or private equity firm
you still have a lot of people going
into academia despite the lack of
compensation they make more than k-12
teachers but not nowhere near what they
would what those same people would make
if they went into industry
and i think the reason why really really
really smart people and not to say that
really really smart people aren't going
to k-12 but it's just their their
threshold of passion has to be so high
that it can overcome these other things
but the reason why you you have
less of a problem in the higher
education is i think you have a high
degree of respect and actually i'll add
independence i would say independence at
the higher education level that to some
degree the reason why you become a
professor at university is that
obviously you get a lot of intellectual
stimulation but you get a ton of respect
and you get a lot of independence
especially once you once you get tenure
and so i think
i think the solution here is get
compensation compensation is important
compensation has to go up i think it has
to at least get comparable to university
professors and so in this day and age
you know that that's definitely in the
uh well a lot higher than where teachers
are paid right now but they don't have
to get to investment banking salaries
but i think even more importantly they
have to be fields where teachers can
express their creativity and um
they you know they're they're given much
more power and respect than in a lot of
cases uh
they're given right now and and
definitely even independence and i think
this is a role that we have is that
every every iteration every time
government officials panic about the
education system they just micromanage
it more and that might in their minds
de-risk the worst that's going on but it
also handicaps the best that's going on
and so it makes it it forces teachers to
lose their independence and uh
we hope what we're advocating is that it
in it makes the teachers it gives them
more independence to do what they want
with class time because so much is now
taken off of uh kind of taken so much of
the core stuff has now taken students
can do
through through the khan academy
and then the last question extra credit
what is the the next big step
for the academy and i hinted at this
several times we are expanding the
faculty
so that is a really big thing um and
outside of that we're just continuing to
layer on more features we're adding a
lot more content on the exercise side
and uh i think you'll start to see in
the next six months to a year exercises
that go beyond our core math because our
videos obviously already go well beyond
math but you'll start seeing exercises
that go beyond that but i think the next
really big one that you're gonna that's
going to make waves is uh the the
faculty members that that are not me